Conor McGregor this episode is a special
one for you with a special message that
a lot of these fighters whatever
whatever they're in all of these sports
figures to be honest for the last 40
years all they've been doing is
imitating Muhammad Ali trying to be like
Muhammad Ali they had the famous George
st. Pierre who's a UFC fighter we did a
show specifically also for him I can't I
can't sleep at night now I'm going crazy
at the shoes man I and I need to relax I
need to get out for a while you know um
I don't know what I'm gonna do any I am
you do that sometimes God humbles you
too because and not because God doesn't
like you and it's not even but actually
if God umbels you in this life when
you're saying something like that is
actually a sign that God wants something
good for you that's that you can could
let you keep going and going and not
humble you but now is the time to
reflect that's why it's good that God
humbles us sometimes and we all have
that this in our life even if we're not
you know champions and we're not in show
business we all have times where become
things are going well we become very
sure of ourselves we think oh I have
this job I have this car I have this
money because of me because I work hard
and sometimes God has to Humble us a
little bit know we know I want aspect
it's show business right and many people
don't understand that even as human
beings you know you'll say one word
you'll destroy a marriage you'll say the
wrong paragraph wrong son you end up in
life in jail in prison but now the words
we say against the Almighty I'm killed
with all the gods gods recognize gods
I was gonna get it regardless sooner or
later it's coming with or without you
and then the God came and blessed you
Willie know about that coffee me any man
God man I mean not only that I whipped
God as well I'm the one who's created us
giving us all these blessings that you
couldn't even throw a punch
a jab blocker punch without these
blessings from God to insult God like
this are we thinking what do you think
I'm telling you what I'm gonna pray that
God strikes this guy dead do you know
why he's name is Conor McGregor yes and
he's a UFC I mean these so many guys
these guys are table strike him dead I
mean whatever car and I'm one who gave
you the abilities and the one who
actually put that treasure there who
doesn't need any of it but just put it
there to test you that when you achieve
the success will you recognize the one
who gave you the ability to be
successful and now what will you do with
all of that